واحد
جاء
وقتل طفله
تيجي نظريه تقول ايه هو على اساس شعور
بانه بيحقق ذاته كذا وكذا
طيب جاء واحد ثاني وانقذ طفل من الغرب قال
برضو
[موسيقى]
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح
قريت تغريده قبل كم يوم للدكتور محمد قاسم
يقول
العلم ترى لكي تؤمن
بعض المدارس الاخرى تؤمن لكي ترى انت
تغريده
صحيح ان كثير قد يختلف معها لكن هي تفتح
باب اسئله بالنسبه لي من يحدد هذا علم
وهذا مو حلو هل فقط العلوم التجريبيه هي
العلم لانك تقدر تختبرها بس هي كذلك ممكن
تكون خطا يقال ان العلم فقط هو اللي قابل
لان يكون خطا طيب على كده
فلسفه
ماذا عن العلوم
الحديثه للضبط البشريه
فابرجع للسؤال الاساسي من اللي يحدد انه
هذا الحقيقي هذا علم مزيف ونقدر نفتح باب
المزيف
ونمشي ولا ننتهي
في اليوم احنا نعيش فتره من كم المعرفه
وسهوله الوصول اليها اللي يخلي مثل هذه
النقاشات مهمه
فهذه حلقه نقاشيه مع الدكتور عبد الله
البريدي المهتم بالفلسفه فلسفه العلم
قبل ان نبدا شاركوني اسماء ضيوف او مواضيع
تقترحونها على فنجان على بريد البرنامج
فنجان الثمانيه دوت كوم
اما الان
انا انا لا هذا ما هذا تمرضون انتم
والله تمام
بدون سكر ما يكلف
انت مره مرتين بس يا بنت الحموضه
النوم مره لا لا وهذيك صورك حلو ما تقدر
انت تحكم على الشيء بلا جربته كذا مره
يعني اكون مضطر احيانا بالسعوذ بالله لازم
احط معه حليب اذا اضطررت يعني
لا انا اشرب القهوه العربيه حقتنا ولا فيك
بعدين انا مره مرات يعني تركته يمكن حدود
15 سنه
يمكن عشر سنوات وبعدين شفتنه حلوه اصلا
بديت انا الحين اشرب رمضان وبعدين
اشترك 15 سنه يمكن ارسل صوره تركتها لاني
انا راعي
وقتها ودي اكثر المنبهات عندي لاني انا من
الاول خمس سمسميه تشربها البليار
دو الضغط
كان يقول
انها
ان النبات
كان عاقل
وفي عقل فهو سواء تجربه يعني وكيف ان
النبات صار يعد الثواني ومدري شفت المقطع
او لا بس لك اياها لكن
استغربت يعني والله
فكره ان النباتات
هو هو هو يعني قضيه انه الكائنات هذه
لانها خاليه من اي نوع من انواع الادراك
فكره صعب تقبلها ترى
ولذلك يكون الله سبحانه وتعالى عرض
الامانه على الارض والسماوات والجبال فبين
يحملنها شوف يعني
السماوات والارض
ما نتذكر رساله
جالس افكر صراحه اي نوع من انواع التعقل
عند السماوات والارض والجبال حتى تصل
لدرجه انها تكلف برساله
طبعا هذه من الاسرار التي لا يعلمها احد
عنها وقال بعض الفلاسفه يعني كلام طويل
حول ولكن الصعب يعني الجسم بها لكن
صعب
يعني وهو يسويها تتفرج
اذا النبات تمسك العشي وبرضو تذكر فيه اذا
على الانسان طبعا نشيل العقل
هو وين هو في الدماغ ولا في القلب
هنا ناس
دينيه
بس اذا بده اليوم
الجماعه
هو لذلك وذلك شوف ابو عمر يعني هذا ايضا
قضيه يعني يعني نحن اا في التراث العربي
الاسلامي يعني عندنا ايه لهم قلوب يعقلون
بها
او اذان يسمعون بها اذا شيء لا احد
يسمعونا بها معناته وظيفه الاذن السماعه
وظيفه العق- القلب التعقل
صعب انك همم
تنسف ان العقل ما عنده علاقه بالعقل
والتعقل والادراك صعب حتى انه في بعض
الابحاث الان وجد انه بعض على جدار القلب
في خلايا عصبيه
ايه ولذلك
يعني هل العقل في القلب ولا في الدماغ
الصوره غير واضحه وغير محسومه وانا اعتقد
ان احتاج الى عدد من الابحاث لكنه من
الناحيه المعرفه الدينيه وحنا المعرفه
الدينيه ترى المسلمين احنا يعني نعتدئ بها
كثير يعني هذا نص قراني الهي وبالتالي لما
يقول لهم قلوب يعقلون بها انا اعرف ايش
معنى
الحق ولذلك حتى العلماء بالتراث اختفى على
قولهم قالوا انه العقل موجود بالدماغ ليش
قالوا اسباب
على راسه يفقد العاقله شيء وقالوا ان
العرب كانوا يقولوا للعاقل وافر الدماغ
ولغير العاقل خفيف الدماغ يعني
دلال حسي عمليه الضرب ودلاله اللغويه
باللغه العرب والبعض قالوا لا ان العقل
موجود في القلب في دلاله هذه الايات لهم
قلوب يعقلون بها المساله غير محسومه شوفي
غير محسوم بالتراث غير محسوم الان بالعلم
انا عميل الى انه القلب له ضيف الكبرى في
العقل
مع وظائف يعملها الدماغ
لكن وفق قال بهيم عليه القلب كان الدماغ
يتلقى اوامر تعليمات توجيهات من القلب
بطريقه معقده لم اكتشفها بعد العقل
اكيد
يعني شوف اصلا الانسان اصلا ما يمكن
تفكر يعني عندما اصل الانسان يعني مستوى
الواعي عنده مستويات
ولم تجد انك
يعني تعي انا اعين يا عبد الله وانت عندك
عبد الرحمن
وتعي انك تعي
وهذا مستوى سمعي الواعي
ولذلك
لانه يعني انه يعي فيعي انه يعداته
الاخر ويعيى انه يعني الاحساس بالعالم
الطبيعه
وهذا مستويات
عبد الرحمن وعبد الله
لا احنا شخصيات كثيره انا مره من مرات
وصلتهم الى 16 شخصيه
16 شخصيه مثلا من ضمن الاحتمالات
فيه عبد الله
اللي انا اعي نفسي انه عبد الله هذا واحد
وفي عبد الرحمن
فيه الشخصيه عبد الله اللي وده يصير عبد
الله
وعبد الرحمن
في عبد الله اللي وده تظاهر انه عند الناس
المحبه الله صاروا سته
واضح وفي عبد الله اللي يعتقد ان الناس
ينظرون له صاروا ثماني
وهكذا انا مره وصلتهم بس يمكن ما كتبته
يعني لازم افكر مره ثانيه فاذا اذا
مستويات عجيبه الانسان مستويات عجيبه
اصلا
وبالتالي عندك عندك يعني جانبين مهمين من
العقل عندك ادراك
نفسه يعني المحيط اللحوم
الادراك
حواس حولك
يعني مثيرات
اصوات
روائح انوار مثل انوار موجوده الان
بالاستديو الى اخره من هذه الاشياء عندك
الله سبحانه وتعالى عندنا صار عندنا ركب
لنا حواس الحواس هذه تلتقط المثيرات
المسيرات تمر الى الدماغ
وفق فاهم انا الان بس مثل ما قلنا قبل
قليل لانه القلب واضح انه له علاقه بطريقه
مبهمه حتى الان فا عندما عندما تمر هذه
المثيرات المنقوله عبر الحواس الى الدماغ
تيجي عمليه نسمي احنا عمليه التفسير شلون
عمليه التفسير انه هل مثير هذا خبر معين
التقدم تويتر اعلان معين يعني مثلا والله
طالب جامعي شاف انه الكليه معلنه انه
الكليه ستكرم
الطالب وتسميه طالب الشهر او طالب الفصل
الطالب الكري في الجيد يقول اكيد انهم
يشتغلون على المعدلات
لانه وجهه نظره هو اللي يعكس الطالب اللي
يستحق انه يكره الطالب اللي دائما
بالاعمال التطوعيه وكذا يقول اكيد هذا
اللي بيكرم لان هذاك اخذ حقه بالمعدل
المفروض اني انا اكره مثلا اذا لاحظ ان
التفسير
لان الحين المدير
الطالب هذا يعتبر مثير وخبر انتقل للحواسه
شفته
عمليه التفسير حنا دائما نقول
تتاثر بخبراتك الماضيه
ومشاعرك ااا
الحاضره وتطلعاتك المستقبليه
بالتالي كان التفسير عباره عن صبغ لون
تلون التفسير وفواحد يقول كده واحد يقول
كده وواحد يقول كده الى اخره ولذلك المثير
او الخبر
اللي انت تلتقطه الان وتفسره يتاثر بحالك
المزاجيه
وبتلاحظ انه في اشياء امس كنت فسرتها
بطريقه اليوم او بعد اسبوع فسرت بطريقه
مختلفه نفس الخبر نفس المثير وشلت تغير
تغير في شيء دخلت اصلا اللي هو اللي احنا
نسميه
العوامل السياقه
يمكن ادخل اليوم قريت فكره
دائما انا اقول الانسان اللي يريد ان يكون
اكثر فعاليه واكثر تميزا واكثر نجاحا وكذا
يجب عليها ان يعي
بالوعي بمعنى انه انت ما تفكر بالموضوع لا
اطلع من نفسك يعني عبد الرحمن يطلع وعبد
الله يطلع فانت بتفكر بالموضوع لا تفكر
بطريقه تفكيرك
وهذا ترى او شيء كبير يعني تفكر بطريقه
تفكيرك على اذا فكرت بطريقه تفكيري بموضوع
معين سادرك انه والله عندي الثغرات
الفلانيه
نقاط ضعف همم
قاعد استخدم
كل الحلال
التحليلي مثلا في التفكير يصلح للحالات
اللي فيها منطق
لكن تعال للاشياء اللي تم فيها جديد
يصح نمط التركيبي نمط التركيبي لانه هو
اللي يقودك الابداع انك تفكر تركب شيء على
شيء فهمت انا يا سيد انا ما ابيك مهندس
مهندس صحابي تفكير تحليلي
انت بتعمل لي بنايه وذلك لاحظ الفرق بين
مهندس المدني المهندس المعماري مهندس
المعدني يمين ليش لانه التفكير التحليلي
المنطقه
الاعمده تكون بطريقه
مختلفه بناء عشان نجاه العواصم جاءت
العشاء ما يسقط
هذه محسوبه بالرياضيات لكن المهندس
المعماري لا اذا بتفكير تركيبي ابداعي
خيال الى اخره فانت مثلا مثل ما قلنا اذا
ما فكرت بطريقه تفكيرك تجد انك ضايع لانك
20 30 سنه وانت مستخدم نمطين وفي ثلاث
اربع خمسه انماط يمكن
ما استخدمتنا ابد او استخدمتها بشكل ضعيف
طيب هل في فرق بين
العقل والفكر
بدنا نفرق بينها كيف ال ال ال العقل هو
عمليه التعقد يعني عمليه التفكير اللي انت
تقوم الفكر المقصود فيها التراكم
للافكار والممارسات ضمن التراث الانسان
بمعنى انك انت عندك تفكير لكنه في فكر
متابعه محصله للافكار اللي والممارسات
والتجارب والنظريات التي ابدعها الاخرون
فانت تفكر فيه في هذا الفكره لكن احنا
نسميه الفكر الانساني والتفكير التفكير هو
عمليه ذهنيه انسان
وتستخدم الفكر الانساني ضمن المدخلاتك
فالفكر يكون مدخرا ضمن المدخلات التفكير
والمدخلات هذه تشكل المعرفه فكل معلومه
اعرفها هي بالضروره معرفه صرت انا عارف
فيها
طبعا هنا نيجي المصادر المعرفه
مصادر المعرفه
طبعا خلينا نتكلم عن مصادر المعرفه وفق
تراثنا العربي الاسلامي احنا مشكلتنا
انه في العون يعني في العقود الاخيره
جعلنا المنظر الغربي هو ينظفر لنا ويضع
لنا
مصادر المعرفه وما الى ذلك
المصادر المعرفه حنا نضعها في عده مصادر
المصدر الاول ماستر الخبر الخبر المقصود
في النص الدين
من اعلى المصادر انه ماستر ديني
مقدس
معرفه واضحه ودقيقه
فبالتالي هذا اكبر مصدر اذن هذا المصدر
الخبر موجود في القران الكريم والسنه
النبويه الصحيحه
وضمن المسلمين نحن الثوابت
ومسمي القطعي قطعي الثبوت قطعي الدلاله
ممتاز هذا المسطر الاول المصدر الثاني
مصدر الحواس
مصدر الحواس يدخل فيه كل حواسك يدخل في
المنهج التجريبي انك بتاخذ ماده تحطه على
ماده بالمعمل وتشوف ايش تنتج تنتج ماده
الف باء جيم دال اذا نحس والتجربه هذا
المصدر
ويدخل طبعا الملاحظه ويسمى منهج الاستقرار
الى اخره في العلم
المنهج الثالث هو المنهج اللي احنا نسميه
المنهج الاستنتاجي او الاستنباطي هذا
بالعقل بالتفكير
عندك معلومات معينه
تستخدم
مناهج تفكير التجريد والتركيب والتركيك
وكذا وكذا وانا ما اعطى التفكير اللي قلنا
عنهم قبل شوي وغيرهم حتى تصل نتيجه معينه
هذا منهج عقلي تحليلي استنتاج استنباقي
مسطر الثالث
في مصدر رابع ومستر شوي غامق بنسمير ماستر
الحدثي
وبصراحه انا اقبله بس اقبله
ليش
لانه احنا نقول النظريه مثلا اذا انت مثلا
عالم تبي تجيب نظريه ترى النظريه ما تيجي
من التجربه عمره النظريه العلميه ما اجت
من التجربه مباشره
وتقول لك والله اذا صار كده بيصير كده
تعطيه فروض تعطي قوانين لكن نظريه يحتاجها
الوثبه اللي قلنا الوثبه دي عمليه حسيه
عمليه دهنيه مبهمه مركبه غامضه فيها غموض
بس انا ليش اقول بحذر لانه مشكله بعض
الصوفيه والدروشه
والخزعبلات هذه يعني عادي يشتغلون
بالموضوع هذا يعني يضعونه ويفتحون الباب
على مسرحين هذه مشكله عشان كذا احنا لازم
صراحه همم ما نرفض الشيء تماما بس نقبله
بحذر منهج
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر في
تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول بكفاءه
وذكاء سلوشن سبايسي
[موسيقى]
الى هذه المصادر الرابع
شلونكم مع الفكره غربي فيه انه ممكن ناخذ
من عندهم النتائج ولا الافكار اللي عندهم
ونطبقها على الانترنت
والمصدر الخبري عن طريق النص الديني
والمصدر الحادسي لانه اساسي طبعا ليس كل
غربيين نحس المسطره عشان كذا هم عندهم
جوانب ابدعوا فيها
يعني مثلا المنهج التجريبي عندهم جوانب
يعني صراحه يعني
اسهموا في تقدم منهج التدريب بشكل مظهر بس
قصدي انه انت عشان تحصل على المعرف ان كل
المصادر
انك انت ما يكون عندك عشان كذا انا صراحه
ادعو الى ديمقراطيه المعرفه مشكله الانسان
الغربي
في الفكر وانا بتكلم عن جانب الفكر
الفلسفه
يعني مثلا تيجي واحد ياخذ المنهج
الاستنتاجي الاستنباطي وينسف الاستقرار
والحسد والتجربه وتيجي ناس العكس
فهم عندهم نظرات يعني يكونون على قدر من
التطر من التطرف لذلك حتى يسمونها يسمونه
يسمونه حرب البارده
حروب فلسفيه وللك ياخذ البحث النوعي
والكيفي ما يرى بالبحث الكميائي واللي يرى
البحث الكمي ما يقبل البحث النووي احنا
نقول له البحث النوع علو مجاله
وهكذا فبالتالي احنا يعني الحمد لله الفكر
العربي الاسلامي نغمه المعرفه نوع من
المعرفه لها مصادر وكل ماستر ثري وغني في
مجاله
تساعد البشريه في الوصول الى حضاره اكثر
عنقل
لا ما اعتقد لا على العكس كل واحد يبغى
يثبت نفسه اه او يثبت فكره ومنهجيه
اللي انت ترمي اليه هي يعني قضيه حتى
احيانا يعبر عنه بالمفهوم الجدل
هذا انه الفكره ونقيبها يتفاعلون مع بعض
وينتج بالنهايه مركب شامل يشمل الفكره
ونقلها ثم هذا المركب
يولد نقيضه ثم يتفاعلون ويتصارعان وهكذا
لا لا بد ليس صحيح بمعنى انه شوف الحضاره
العربيه الاسلاميه حضاره تراها مدهشه في
العلوم وفي الاختراعات وفي تشقق العلوم
وما عندهم يعني ما يلزم الايكون الفكر
صناعي صدام حتى حتى ينمو العلم لا ليس
صحيحا بالعكس انا اخسر انا عندما انحي
مثلا مصدر الخبريه
او يعني اتحمس اكثر من اللازم للمنهج
الحسي تجريبي على المنهج الاستنتاجي
العقلي انا اخسر
لكن عندما اقول نحن مدارس
والله عبد الله مدرسه ال ال ال ال ال الحس
والملاحظه والتجربه عبد الرحمن مدرسه
الاستنتاج والتحليل العقلي حنا مدارس انت
تشتغل وانا اشتغل
فكوني مثلا انا واياك يصير بيني وبينك جدل
انه الموضوع الفلاني الافضل انه يدرس
بالمنهج الحسي بالملاحظه والتجربه وانا
اقول لك لا جيد ترى موجود في التراث على
فكره يعني الجدر هذا موجود بس ليس ليس
جدلا صراعيا اقصائيا بحيث اني اقول لك لا
ما تعتبر اصلا مصادر المعرفه بس وهذه وهذا
النفس التمرد الموجود في الفلسفه الغربيه
همم في الحقيقه وعند التمعون اضر بالمعرفه
الانسانيه ولم يعرف
انه برضه في التاريخ الاسلامي
ان الصراع كان محتدم ما بين العلوم يعني
ابن سينا
وغيره ما كان مراحب فيهم في المجتمع
الاسلامي وخصوصا المجتمع العلمي فهم كانوا
ففيه تطرف ما بين انه هو كافر ملحد لان
جالس ياخذ العلوم التجريبيه ولان المسلمين
اللي في الجانب الاخر
فتطرف موجود في كل
اذا اخذتها اليوم في السعوديه اذا بناخذ
على الوقت الحاضر فتلقي ان احنا اكثر
تطرفا في العلوم الدينيه وناخذها ان هي
اللي فيها العلماء اليوم انت تقول عالم في
السعوديه ما يحضر في ذهنك
في كل تركيزناه على العلوم الدينيه
والجامعات في العلوم الدينيه اكثر ازدهارا
من اي علوم اخرى فالعلوم التطبيقيه
التجريبيه لا كان تكون موجوده
في المجتمع الحاضر الاسلامي تاخذ اجمالانا
العربي او السعودي
خلينا نبدا
الشيء الاخير بعمر الورد يعني مثلا شف
مثلا كانت اتفق مع ملاحظه الاخير تمام يا
ابو عمر هو عندنا مشكله
انه في الاونه الاخيره وربما بسبب خطاب
ديني معين تمام همم يعني خلينا نكون يعني
صريح يعني الدين السلفي وهذا لا يعني انه
لما ننقد جانب ان انا اسف كل الحسنات هذا
الخطاب لا عنده جواهر ممتازه ولا نعمم
ايضا انه ليس كل من ينتمي لهذا الخطاب في
ناس هذا الرائعين وشاطرون ان الفكره ربما
يكون عندهم نترات اعمق
لكنه السما العام في فترات معينه لهذا
الخطاب الديني
همش العلوم غير الدينيه طيب احنا ابو عمر
نرجع احنا وياهم ليش القراني شوف الله
سبحانه وتعالى يقول في القران واضحه
قل هل يستوي الذين يعلمون والذين لا
يعلمون
ترى الايه هذه فيها جانب ادهاش لغوي مبهر
متعلق باللغه العربيه
لغه تتخيل ان اللغه
تعبير مدهش مبهر لهذا ال- ال- الفيلسوف
اللغوي المبهرني رحمه الله يخش الجامعه
العربيه
واضافه عندها نفي واثبات عندها تنكر
التعريف يقول هذه الاشياء اللي تمارس
اللغه فيها شجاع لانها تعطي معنا عاده
المعنى حتى حتى بمعنى اكثر عاده تعطي
كلمات زياده
يسمونه زياده المعنى بسبب زياده المبنى
تمام هنا اللغه العربيه تخيل تعطيك معنى
اعمق
بزياده المبنى زياده الكلمات لا بنقص
المبنى بنقص الكلمات هنا في الايه هل
يستوي الذين يعلمون والذين لا يعلمون حذف
المفعول به وايش هو المفعول به او اللي هو
الشيء المعلوم
يعني المفروض يقول الذين يعلمون
في الدين دين او اخلاقا او كذا لا هو
الشيء المعلوم
تركه لم يتحدث عنه ليش علشان يعطي الثقل
للفعل اللي هو التعلم عشان تتعلم في كل
مجلات
هذا القران هذا شوف شوف القران
يدفعنا فعلا اننا ندخل في العلوم كلها ما
قال نعم ما نص على العلوم الدينيه قال
الذين يعلمون باي شيء والذين لا يعلمون
اذا هي رساله واضحه عشان كذا انا اقول حتى
بقالب رياضي للناس اللي يحبون الرياضيات
لما اجي الفعل يعلمون واعطيه 100% طبعا
الفعل عاده باللغه العربيه الفعل لو فاعل
ومفعول لما بالعادي يكون الفعل جنبه فاعل
ومفعول فاقسم 100 على اثنين تعطيه 50 لما
يكون المفعول به غير موجود اقسميه على
واحد لانه بس الفاعل
يعلمون الواو اللي فاعل السر 100 قسمه
واحد السر 100 بتصير النيه هذه كلها رايحه
القوه للفعل اللي هو انك الله يقول لك
تعلم باي مجال
هنا اذا الخطاب الديني لما يجي يركز على
العلوم الدينيه فقط معناته لم يستوعب مراد
الله سبحانه وتعالى في اننا نتعلم كل
العلوم هذا امر امر اخر انه ترى
الباحث المسلم المتخصص بالاقتصاد هو الشيخ
الاقتصاد
المتخصص في السياسه هو الشيخ وعالم الدين
السياسي المتخصص في التنميه هو عالم الدين
وهكذا احنا مشكلتنا انه الشيخ عالم الدين
يفتي في علوم الدين التي الذي هو فعلا
يعني متمكن منها يفترض بها وفق التخصصات
طبعا لكن ما المشكله في كل شيء غلط انت
يا عالم الدين مع محبتنا واجراننا لك لا
تفهم شيئا انت انسان عادي وعمي في
الاقتصاد في السياسه في التنميه في بعض
علوم الانسان
انت يعني انت مثلك انت تعطي رايا مثل اي
راي اخر
فنحن نقول هذا ماجلان العلماء انه
بيننا وبينكم كلمه سواء وهو كلام الله
سبحانه وتعالى
يعلمون ولا يعلمون برضه ما في مفعول به
يعني يعلمون في حقلهم فبالتالي اذا هنا
يعني هذا
الوضع العلمي بطريقه ممتازه ويكون عندنا
علماء دين علماء انسان وعلماء طبيعه
ولاحظ انا مره اخرى
هؤلاء علماء علماء الانسان هم علماء الدين
في الانسان وعلماء المسلمين بالطبيعهم
علماء الدين في الطبيعه
وهؤلاء وكل واحد يفتي في مجاله
هذا بالنسبه للجزء الاول شوف الجزء الاول
من السؤال
انا باتحدث عن التاريخ شفت الجمال
بالموضوع انه نعم يكون في تدل مثل ما قلت
لك بس انه تراه وانا يهمنا محصله الفكره
ماذا تقول انا ما يهمني والله في ناس
انحاز والمستر الفلاني والطريقه الفلانيه
في مصدر المعرفه كتب
مفيده بعدين لانه مدارس لما يكون بينها
جدل قوه انت لما تكون ضدي
هم من الفكر نفسه هل هو ينحي بالنهايه
الفكر ابو عمر
الفلسفه الغربيه
اسلاميه او الفلسفه مغربيه الرئيس
وهذا له طبعا يحتاج انك تكون قارب مطلع
عشان تعرف وجهه التيار الرئيس داخل الفكره
العربي
اللي مثل النسق العام الاكبر اللي احنا
نقول مثلا بلغه العلوم الشرعيه الجمهور
اللي عليها الجمهور جمهور جمهور العلماء
جمهور الفلاسفه جمهور مفكرين فانت اذا
نظرت للفكره العربي
قبل شوي طبعا نكون في ناس يكونوا ضد ما ضد
مثل هذه وقوي لانه اي واحد يهاجمك انت
بتخليه منهجك يعني فعلا قويه وعنده
ابراهيم وعنده ادلل هذا مفيد
للعلم والعلوم انت قلت انه لكل حضاره حقها
في تعريف العلم صح ف همم
عند المسلمين العرب
هو في قضيه مهمه جدا لا بد انا عارف ان
العلم اصلا ايش يشتغل عليها يشتغل على
واحد بسيط لازم يعني ولذلك انا من ضمن
الاشياء بصراحه اللي اللي تسوه انا ابو
عمر
انه بعض الاساتذه والاكاديميين ربما
الباحثين خلينا العلم اسراره وطلع اسم
وكانوا هذا حقنا
انتم ناس عاديين وعوام ولا بشغل لكم بس
اقرا وشننتج غير صحيح ابدا غير صحيح
الانسان العادي
وحتى اللي ماله علاقه بالعلم ولا منتجه
العلم يفترض انه يفهم العلم
مش العلم
كيف يعمل متى ينجح متى يخفق
ليش ليش يفهم ليش ما يفهم العلم يهتم فيه
ابو عمر وانت من استيقاظك يا اخي الى ما
تنام قال لك خطا صح افعل لا تفعل لا تنام
بالطريقه ذي لان في بحث قال لا انا
بالطريقه دي وانت تمشي لحالها وتجري تمر
حديد واحد بحث يقول لك لا لا تاجر
كل ثلاث بيضات
يوميا الواحد يقول لا بيضه ثلاثه ايام
هتقول لا تاكل الصفار واحد يقول لك واحد
يقول لك همم
غمض غمض عيونك وردت انا قوي انا مستقبل
انا داعي تخيل دائره اسمها دائره التميز
داخل انا مميز انا طبعا
جالس يعطى توجيهات بحياتنا طيب انا انا
كانسان حتى لو انا بعيد كل البعد عن العلم
مونتاج لا بدي افهم وشلون العلم هذه قضيه
مهمه طيب ارجع واقول ان العلم هو
المبدا اللي يشتغل عليه العلم هو مبدا
بسيط نسميه مبدع الانتظام
او الثبات او الاطراف هو
انه ما حصل بالامس قبل شهر شهرين بيحصل
اليوم بيحصل غدا
يحسب السعوديه عشان مباراه الارجنتين
السعوديه
تمام هذا اسمه انتظار انتظام
في العالم في الطبيعه
الواحد
حبي يدرس مثلا سلوك شجره معينه من الاشجار
ما في انتظام اذا ما في علم
لكن تعال مثلا الى مبدا يقول لك الاشياء
الثابته مثل الكوب هذا تبقى ثابته ما لم
تاتي قوه خارجيه متحركه وتنقولها من حاله
الثبات الى حاله الحركه والاشياء المتحركه
ستبقى متحركه ما لم تاتي قوه خارجيه وتنقل
من حال الحركه الى حاله السكون هذا القرن
الاول
في انتظام
يحصل في كل مكان بالعالم
القبض على الاضطراد في العالم اي شيء
منتظمه اي شيء مهم منتظم
تسولف لا لازم تعرف انه في انتظام طبعا
الانتظام في في وضع الطبيعه في عالم
الطبيعه اكبر من انتظام في عالم الانسان
لان الماده ماده جامده لما احطها في
المعمل على ماده ثانيه تعطيني ماده جيم
مهيب على كيفك تقول انا بصير جيم ولا دار
لا فالاضطراد في الطبيعه اكثر من على
الانسان عنده روح وعنده اراده ما تضمنها
نروح والاراده
مو بشرط يعطيك نفس السلوك يمكن يغير يمكن
مزاجه يمكن يصير عنده مرجعيه دينيه
اخلاقيه يمكن يصير عنده عقد هم وافهم بس
يعطيك سلوك اخر فالانتظام في عالم اللسان
اقل لكن لابد من الانتظام علشان اقدر اقول
اني عندي علم ايش انساه اذا المبدا ده هو
تراه يعني
الاضطراد والانتظام في الطبيعه موجود في
القران
يعني شف الايه لو كان فيهما الهه الا الله
لفسدتا لو كان فيهما السماوات والارض الا
الله غير الله يعني ما في الا الى واحد
لو كان في اكثر من اله كان كل واحد بيكون
عنده اراده عنده حكمه عنده برنامج عنده
رؤيه عنده خطه كان كل واحد اشتغل يخرب
الثاني عليه
عشان كذا شوف الاضطراد موجود هل نضع في
وزاره اكثر من وزير في مدرسه اكثر مدير في
جامعه في دوله اكثر من حاكم
هذا الاله يعطيني سر التماسك في الوجود
وهذا مبحث الفلسفه المبحث الاول ومبحث علم
الوجود والانطولوجيا اذا التوحيد
اعطاني المبحث الاول في الفلسفه والمبحث
الوجود الانطولوجيا هل وجود العالم متماسك
العالم
ايضا يعطيني قضيه انه وجود الاله واحد وضع
قوانين واحده ونواميس ثابته في الكون وهذا
المبدا اللي متعلق مبدا المعرفه فلسفه
العلم والاستمولوجيا وهو المبحث الثاني في
الفلسفه
وجود اله واحد
هو مصدر الخلق والاخلاق هذا المبحث الثالث
في الفلسفه والاكسولوجيا شوف ايه واحده
في القران
يعني كتاب عظيم بس هن للاسف ما قراناه
بهذا الطريقه اذا لاحظنا التوحيد بدون هذا
التوحيد ما في عالم متماسك ما في اضطراد
وبالتالي ما في علم ولا في معرفه
ولذلك نحن نقول انه لا معرفه ولا علم بدون
اضطراد ولا اضطراد بدون توحيد اذا لاحظنا
المسلم وهو يقرا القران ترى عنده اساس
منهج عظيم عشان كذا هذا هذا الحين انت
العلم يقوم على مبدا الانتظارت
طيب نيجي امر ثاني متعلق بقضيه اييه وظائف
العلم
عشان استطيع اني ابدا افهم العلوم بطريقه
جيده
وظائف العلم اربع وظائف
عندك وظيفه الوصف من العلم يصرف الاشياء
كيف تحدث
في وظيفه اعلى شويه واعمق هي وظيفه
التفسير
يعني ما يصف فقط
تجري او تحدث على هذا المنوال اذا هذه
السببيه العليه
العلم افترضنا مو بس يصف يفسر لانه بس
مجرد كلام تنظيف
يعطيك تحكم
بالاشياء
ولذلك شوف مثلا
قضيه انترنت الاشياء
وانت مت الاجساد صارت جزء من الانترنت
الاشياء تتمثل الاجساد مثل الساعات الحين
الساعه يمكن الا الكلاب
والجهاز الهضمي وتحفيز للدماغ قطاع
الانترنت الاشياء متوقع انه يصل
45 مليار 20 28
يعني بعد ست سنوات
جميله اعطاني السيارات الطائرات الكهربا
بالانترنت شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي التحكم
انت الحين تروح البيت
كل التحكم كنترول
بس برضو العلم كل سبب المشاكل الصغير
والكبيره التلوث الاستنساخ الرقائق هذه
مصيده شبكه التواصل الاجتماعي الادمان
الروبوتات التي تقضي على ملايين الوظائف
اذا العلم مثل والقنابل المدمر هاذا العلم
قدر ما يعطينا وفي جيد ويعني في جانب سيئه
مضره مخيفه ومقلقه عشان كده احنا نقول ان
اي انسان العلم ما هو العلم كيف يشتغل الى
اخره هذه اشياء ترى جدا مهمه
[موسيقى]
وش لقلبك من عشان ادري بنطلع منها
وجود
الشرائح داخل
ابو عمر اشياء كثيره طبعا من ضمن الاشياء
المقلقه ترى انه الانسان بدا يخسر نفسه
بالتدريج بدا يبيع نفسه بالتدريج ترا جدي
وجدك
خارطه جوجل موجوده صح ولا لا الحين انت
انا اتحداك وانت جالس بالرياض اتحداك تروح
يمكن مشوار
من مهاراتك
القدرات الرياضيه الرياضيات
اي والله وشريت من واحد كتابين اظنه 40
و50 واخذ الاله تخيل 40 و50 مو قادر يقول
لي 90 والله العظيم حط طقطق طق 90 كثروا
بالله ما تعرف 90 كلها والله صعبه علي
اذا الانسان جالس يخسر نفسه كانوا يبتر
يعني اطرافه يعني رمزيه
هذا يخلق لانك خلاص تبدا همم الاشياء اللي
كنت تستغلها تفكر شغل الذاكره المعلومات
اللي بتصير موجود
بصير في تحكم بالانسان هذا مغلق عشان كده
مثلا روايه 1948
يعني امر مقلق
كل هذه الاشياء الحقيقه انها مقرقه او
يفترض نحن العرب والمسلمين انا ندخل في
النقاش العالمي ما يصير فقط في طور
المفعول به دائما نتقبل
حدد عمليه الشراء ما نخليه مثلا ترى يعني
مثلا اختياره جدا خطيره عشان كده احنا
احنا نحتاج صراحه بعمر الى ناس
ما هو ليس فقط تخصصون بالحاسب او اذا كان
اصطناعي لا نبي ناس تخصهم فلسفه الذكرى
فلسفه
الحاسب الى اخر يعني البعد الفلسفي تراه
ولذلك الوصول الى ما يسمى
بال ما بعد ما بعد الانسان اياه الانسان
الخارق كذا كذا يعني يعني في في قلق شديد
على حول هذا الموضوع ارجع اضيف احب اضيف
الرابع العلم عشان ما ننساه لكن الوصف
والتفسير والتحكم
طلع لاحظ الوصف التفسير تعلق بالماضي
يعني يحقق قدرنا التنبوس في المستقبل
قراءه في المستقبل اذا تقريبا يعني طب
احنا نضيف مثلا يعني في الاطار العربي
نظيف هدف الخامس
لو وضعت هذه الاهداف الخمسه نعتقد ان
العلم يذكر جدا ممتاز الفرق بين العلم
والمعرفه
في قدر من الفروق بالصراحه يعني مثلا يعني
من ضمن من ضمن الاشياء يعني التي تقال
طبعا في جدول كبير بالادبيات السفر ولذلك
احنا نقول عن الله سبحانه وتعالى انه عليم
عثمان بنقول النوع عارف
احنا نقول الله يعلم من قل يعرف
واحنا نقول ما نقول احنا نعلم الله
يعني هذا يعطيك دلاله في العلم
يشير الى
الوصول الى الاشياء كما هي كما هي في
الوجود كما هي على حقيقتها
وهذه طبعا بعض الفلاسفه يسميها مثلا الشيء
في ذلك الشيء في حقيقته
هذا العلم اما المعرفه فهي تشير الى تصور
ذهني معين قد يعبر عن الحقيقه بدرجه كبيره
هذه من الفرقات
طيب ااا اليوم يعني
لما ناخذ نظره العلم فانت تقول انه
في تحريزين في النظر الان غربيه
عندهم العلم التجريبي فهو من حزين اليه
وتكلمنا فيها انه يكثر انه من مصادر
وانهم اخرجوا الدين همم من
فكره وجوده علم يعني ما هو علم ايش اسباب
هذه الحياه
هو يعني من ضمن الاسباب وعمر لو رجعنا
للفكر همم الغربي همم رحنا عندهم يعني
مبتديين يعني صحيح
الرئيس
اخرى تقريبا
اصول الدينيه
كثير عنا بس احنا نتكلم
يعني تضاريس الفكره الغربي
اوروبا كانت غارقه بالجهل وغارقه بحروب
قتال وكانوا يتفنوا بالقتل الوحشي الاخرين
الاخرين
اااه جات فتره فترات همم طبعا هنا تطور
المسلمون وبنام حضاره عظيم وعلم وهندسه
مائيه وقصور واسلحه يعني بطريقه بعد فيها
انسانيه صراحه
لكن المهم وتشقق للعلوم
هم لما احتكروا بالمسلمين
بداوا يقولون العلوم هنا ترى قضيه مهمه ما
نقله كل شيء
عقيدتك ودينك منقله ادبك ما نقلوه
القلوب الطبيعيه قالوا رياضيات والعلوم
الطبيعيه متحركه
[موسيقى]
يا اخي شوف الكنائس
كنائس ضخمه
يعني معناته اخذت من قوات الناس يا اخي
البساطه ليش تعمل الكنيسه
دي تدل على جبرت الكنيسه ترى افترض ان
نتامل صرح كنيسه الضخمه وبعدين بعض
الكنائس اسرائيل
بسكوك الغفران
بدا يبعون انه تعالى نتعاملن قناه الاحد
تعال يلا هذه 100,000
انتقلت لنا اثنين ب 200 انت مصلحين كذا
لاعب 20 30
قضت اتمنى الناس كل الناس يدفعوا قالوا
تعال لا تشرس صكوك الاثام ابوكم
بيت جدي ابن عمي اطلعوا الناس
قالوا تعال ممكن تعمل همم صكوك
المعاصيك المستقبليه يلا بس ادفع في
استغلال
بطريقه
كانت فعلا يعني يعني
تحالفه مع الحاكم السياسي ومتداخلين اصلا
اصلا هو الحاكم السياسي هو راس يعني
الكنيسه بطريقه معينه في الدين اصبح بشعه
في نظره الغربي لانه فعلا يعني استغلال
وكذا
معها صوره النهضه بدات فكره انه يا جماعه
خلونا نطلع شوي وخلونا نقرا شوي بالفلسفه
وخلوا نقرا بالعلوم الطبيعيه لانه العلوم
النص الديني ما يعطي كل شيء نحنا نحتاج
معرفه جايين العلوم الطبيعيه وجاي من
الفلسفه بس انهم ما كانوا بالبدايه مع
انهم عندهم افكار بس يعني صار في نوع من
انواع الملايينه مع التي تيارديني في عقبه
العصر لحظه ولذلك كوبرنيك اسمه مثلا طلع
كتاب سماه كتاب الطبيعه المجيد على وزن
كتاب الرب المجيد شايف ملايه يعني عشان ما
يخسر الخطاب الديني خايفين من خطاب الدين
بعد كذا بدت فعلا يعني تتشرب افكار النهضه
واهميه الفلسفه واهميه العلوم الطبيعيه
وكذا ثم جاء عصر التنوير لما جاء عصا
التنويره بعد عصر النهضه
وطبعا اكبر من الناس اللي ساهموا فيها
الفلاسفه الفلاسفه التنوير في فرنسا لا
هنا صار في نظره عدائيه اخصائيه تجاه
الدين
وصار في اقصى وكذا والكنيسه ويعني في شيء
صار في مغاله عشان كده العلمانيه الفرنسيه
متطرفه جدا تجاه
قضيه نمط تدين لا تجاه الدين
فا اجي واقول كانت سؤال عن
الحيازات تجاه اي فالحيازات هذه اذا جاءت
يعني بسبب هذه التراكمات يعني اقدر اقول
لك انه بدايه الحيازات من العصر الثانويه
افكار ضديه ضد الدين بطريقه فيها تطرف
اللي جعلهم فعلا يرون انه علشان نتقدم لا
بديش همم نشطب على الدين جمله التفصيل بس
برده يعني همم
في الانسان يعني وكل ما تغير سواء عندنا
مثلا في الجانب الاسلامي تقدر تاخذ انه في
في المعرفه لهم في انحاز الاسلام
في فرنسا وهذا طبيعي طبيعي
عشان كده ابو عمر
يعني احنا نفترض نمارس تطبيعا مع التحيز
نفسه همم
ترى الانسان كان متحيز لان في تحيزات
رواجبه وفيه تحيزات التحيز يعني التحيز
للنصه الدين اللي تؤمن فيه يا اخي عندما
يوجد نصف القران انت انت مؤمن تؤمن في
خلاص تسلم هذا تحيز واجب عليك من الجانب
الايماني وفي معرفه في علم ولذلك الان
يعني شوف مثلا القران الان له اكثر من
1400 سنه بجدول تغيرات وكده ما في ما في
ثغرات ما في يعني ثيارات يصمد امام العلم
ما في عشان كده احنا قلنا نصد ديني نحن
عندنا تحيد نسميه تحيز واجب وفي تحيس
محايد يعني مو مرتبه الوجوه مسموحات مقبول
وفيه تحيز لا ينسمي انواع العلم
يعني يعني مثلا يعني هذا الكتاب يعني طبعا
القران في ناس قاعدين يشتغلون على اساس
انه يثبتون انه ليس هو والرساله الخاتمه
لله لبني البشر
وبالتالي يبحثون عن اي ثغره ولذلك
يعني لو كان عندي غير الله لا وجدوا فيه
اختلافا كثيرا ترى هذا تحدي تحدي يلا ابحث
حسيت 100 صفحه ابل
ماء ولذلك شف يعني عمليه الاقتراعات
شوف هذا بالنسبه اذا كان في تصدع على اسم
يتصدع في المعنى كان معي غير لا يوجد في
اختلافا كثيره شوف مثلا ما في حتى تصدع او
عيب او ثغرات في الطبيعه
همم الذي خلق سبع سماوات انطباقا فارجع
البصر هل ترى من فطور في تشقق عيوب
ثم رجع البصره كرهتين ينقلب اليك البصر
خاسئا وهو حزين ما في عيوب يلا جيب جيب
جيب بالخلق الله يتحدى كل احد ما في
ولذلك القران تلاوه نص ديني عظيم ولذلك
انا صراحه اعتقد انه يفترض انه يسوق
القران ليس بوصف نص دينيا المسلمين فقط
وانما هو ترى نص حضاري ليه لان في اضاءات
فلسفيه عظيمه في اضاءات علميه متعلقه
بالانسان بالطبيعه بالمتفيقه كتاب مدهش
القران القران
في ناس تاخذ الاعجاز العلمي في القران
وكذا همم
بصراحه محتاجه يعني يعني بمعنى انه هو
مشكله احيانا ناخذ فكره ونتحمس اكثر الناس
او ما نعطيها ما تستحق يعني ماشي القران
صحيح ليس كتاب علم لكن في اضاءات علميه
ولا ما في
في مفاتيح فانت اذا اردت ولذلك بعض الناس
لا هذا معناته انت ما اخذت فكره القران في
اضاعات مفاتيحنيه
بالضبط عشان كذا احنا لازم نصير بالنص
يعني ما ما ارفض فكره الاجازه العلمي بس
ما اطبقه بالطريقه اللي طبقه بعض
المتحمسين
يعني انس حتى احيانا يعني بعضهم متحمسين
يصل الى انهاء القضيه النظريه ما تيجي
نظريه تنسف النظريه اذا معناته القران
عندك من مضبوط لا اصلا من اللي قال لك ان
هذه وصله درجه النظريه
ولذلك هنا يجيء فكره ابو عمر وهذا يمكن
يهمنا انه العلم وشلون ينمو كيف كيف تطور
العلم علشان يشتغلون بالاعجاز العلمي ما
يقعون بالخطا هذا صراحه افضل ما وصف قصه
تطور العلم
في كتابه شهير جدا
1962 بنيه الثورات العلميه
كان يشتغل يعمل الدكتوراه في الفيزياء
او امريكي
دكتوره جامعه امريكيه فيزياء اخذ ضمن
المقررات في الدكتوراه مقرر اسمه تاريخ
العلم
يعني حبه التخصص جدا وقال انا شكلي ما انا
مكمل بالفيزياء ابي اكمل بتاريخ العلم
خلص شوي على بال بس يخلص الرساله وكذا
وفعلا بعد ما سنوات قليله اخذ مقرر وبدي
يدرس وتاريخ الان لكن بصراحه وصل نتائج
عظيمه بالكتابه الكتابه هذا صراحه من افضل
ما كتب يعني يعني يقال طبعا وانا اتفق
صراحه انه يقال انه من افضل الكتب
الفلسفيه متعلقه
العلم في القرن العشرين وانا اتفق مع احد
كتاب يعني سمين يستحق ان يقرا اكثر من مره
ومترجم على فكره اكثر من ترجمه الجيده
طيب ايش يقول يعني خليها سرديه حدوده قصه
وشجر العلم شلون العلم
اولا
العلم كل علم له جماعه اسمه جماعه علميه
سينتمكن والله انت متخصص اصول الفقه في
جماعه علميه وصول الفقه تخصص بالفيزي في
جماعه فيزيائيه بالكيمياء بالرياضيات
تقول لك انت كباحث يجب استخدم المنهج
وتقاليد واعراف للبحث جمع البيانات التي
تجمع كيف تحلل كيف تصنع نتائج شلون تبرز
الدليل
مره ثانيه رجال القران ما في شيء بالعلم
والفلسفه بالقران موجوده شيء
يبعث على الفخر
المناهج وتشتغل
مره ثانيه
وتصل بقضيه معينه الى شيء منتظم
تصير نظريه
النظريه دي العلميه تفسر الطبيعه والعالم
كيف يعمل كيف يشتغل
تمام
ج النظريه دي تشتغل فعاله سنوات معينه
والناس والابحاث كله تصير موجفا النظريه
والله النظريه تقول كذا وشغاله فعلا تفسر
في شواهد احنا نسميه شواهد سالبه يعني
تجيء حالات واحدات تبدا النظريه ما تفسره
يعني نظريه تقول بيصير كذاني
سمع حالات شواهد سالبه وحالات حدود يعني
النظريه مش قادره تسيطر على الاحباب
طبعا الجماعه العلميه فيهم حرس قديم
مؤمنين بالنظريه الا يقعدون يسمكرون
بالنظريه سمكرومبه بتمسكوهم به تمام
يتشبثون بها
ويعدلوني شوي
تعدل بعض الفرضيه تبدا تفسر خلاص امشيلها
عشر سنوات بس مره ثانيه تطلع حالات تتعاند
النظريه وما يقدر
فيه مجموعه من العلماء الشباب اصحاب
التفكير الخلاق والجزاره يقولوا له
نظريه خلاص طيب ايش نحتاج نحتاج نظريه
نظريه ما يكفينا غير النظريه مش نغير
البارا دائم طيب
هو عباره عن الاشبه ما يكون بالنظاره
لنلبس عشان يشوف العالم
فهمت تخلع النظاره اللي تشوف العالم اصفر
البس اخضر
نموذج ارشادي
يتحكم طريقه انك كيف تنظر بالعالم نفسه
طيب يجون دولا لانهم عندهم عقليات كبيره
جدا في العلم يجون فعلا جديد
اذا العلماء النظارات وبدون ينظرون للعالم
والطبيعه مو جبه البردين من جديد اه
يفصلون الى قوانين جديده ونظريه جديده
وتشتغل معهم فيها
المرحله
لما تيجي مرحله الشدود النظريه ما تشتغل
وكذا وكذا ومحتاج نغير اسميها برده
طيب غيرنا بردايم تغير فعلا نظرات من
العالم والطبيعه استطعت الناس النظريه
الجديده
تعجز عن تفسيره
بحالات الشديد مره ثانيه ثم يجي ناس
يقولون نبي نغير البرد
بصير صراحه
انا اشوف انه بسيط
وفهمت بشكل عام شلون تطور العلم تمام
وبنفس الوقت يعطي يعني نوع من انواع
التوقع وشلون يشتغل
بس
بس افترض ان العلم
يعني لما تطلع نظريه جديده
من الناس تؤمن فيهم مباشر يعني
يطلب منها
اذا اثبتت زي مثلا لما نتكلم عن اذا باخذ
الفكره اللي قبل شوي يحطها على مثال يعني
اتوقع مثلا نيوتن
وانشتاين بالضبط فكرته
انتهت يعني ما يحتاج تناقشني سر صح انت
غلط والله ابو عمر احيانا بعض النظريات
الاتحاد من النظريه النظريه احنا ياخذ
اكثر 100 سنه لا لا لا لا ترى في حرس ما
تتخيل انت يعني احنا ترى عندنا سور ورديه
العلماء
وانا بدي احكي انا بصراحه جزر الصندوق
الاسود في العلم
العلم ترى فيهم تقليديه وتراهم احيانا
يقلدون مشاهير زي زي العوامه
يعني المشهور الفلاني لانه واحد مشهور
يصير ضد النظريه
العلم مثل لما نروح المطعم
مطعم انيق وش الناظر الديكور والكراسي
والطاولات والعمال
نظيف نظيف
المواد المستخدمه نفس جيد صالح لاستخدام
ولا غير صالحه
كانه طبخ نفسه لو زودنا كذا ونقصنا كذا
ويكون اشهى الذ افيد لو قدمت عمليه على
العمال نفسهم هل فعلا انهم على قلب واحد
ومتعاونين ولا كل واحد يحفل الثاني على
شان يخصم عليها ويطرد ها
ترى كده
سالي وبالتالي فيه الخير في الوفاء وفي
الخبز والعلماء عندهم مشاكل وبلاوي يعني
ما قلنا الاشياء اللي تبين هالجوالب هذه
يقول لك انه ممكن واحد يقف ضد نظريه
ومشهور ومقتل انه صح عشان حسد وجوان معين
وعلشان ما ما ما ياخذ ذاك جائزه نوبل
جائزه
نظم الاشياء السلبيه بالعلم الان وصلت
لدرجه ابو عمر ابحاث مفبركه تماما تماما
وخليني اقول قصه ثلاثه طلاب جامعه ام اي
تي امريكا 2005
هذول ثلاثه طلاب مبدعين
قالوا بالحسب الالي كانوا نبي نشوف
المنفضح المؤتمرات العلميه المتوسطه يعني
ضعيفه متوسطه
استخدام خوارزميه معقده
واربطه بقاعده بيانات ضخمه هالخوارزميه
هذه تشتغل على تخلق لك ورقه بحثيه من نفسك
واضح شاهد بعنوان وتعطيك جمل ممتازه ما
فيها اخطاء لغويه ولا فيها سرقه امتحان
يعني يعني ورقه يعني اصيله
يقولون عنها ها
ذي يسموها اس سي ايجن ووو المهم قدموا على
مؤتمر
قبلها
تصير معقده شويه عشان انت تقرا وعندما
صح انا معك
مؤتمر مصلحه وعرض
بعد ما انتو بتعرف نكته يعني بس مجرد هذه
نكته مبين انه بالبحث العلمي اشياء سخيفه
وتخيل انه 2014 هذه كانت 2005 2014 طبعا
خلوا هالبرمجيه هذه خلوها بالانترنت
مفتوحه
طبعا على باله منك خلاص ينكتب وانها
المجتمع العلمي بياخذ الدرس 2014
فضحهم باحث فرنسي اسمه شيرين لا بيه لانه
طور برمجيه تكشف الاوراق المخلقه عبر
البرمجيه هذيك السابقه
120 مخلقه كذا ذاتيه كذا كلام فاضي
عبد الرحمن ابو مالك
واسحبه وتخيم 120
فاا اللي بقوله ابو عمر انه همم لا
النظريات ابو عمر ممكن تجلس فترات طويله
ممكن تجلس 20 30 40 50 سنه ومقاومه احيانا
قد ما هي كلها اي اساس موضوعي بس حسد وانه
لا يحصل على مكافاه لا يصير واحيانا لا
تكون عن قناعات انه مقتنعين يعني انا
مقتنعين من الاول النظريه وارد لكن صدقني
يعني الان تخيل
تدري انت بعمر الان انه حتى في جامعاتنا
العربيه ما يزالون يدرسون الفيزياء
الحتميه يعني
العلم العلم العصر الحديث القائم على فكره
الحتميه هي قريبه من فكره الاضطرارات
فكره الحتميه طبعا ان العلم قادر يشخص كل
المشاكل
يا حلو كل المشاكل من قادر يعطيك الحقيقه
كمان اللي تسمى الحكميه
مع انشتاين وفيزياء والكوميه
انتقلوا مع مبدا هيزنبرج المعروف انت
انتقل العلم من مبدا الحتميه المبدا
اللاحتميه ولا تعيب تخيل الان الى الان
جامعاتنا تدرس فيزياء الحتميه
الفيزياء الفيزياء 1905 196620
الحديث يضبط هذا هذا المساله يضبطها لما
تصبح في مثلا البير ريفيو والمراجعه بين
الاقران تمام
بتخليه انا ما اعرف من انت لكن ورقتك
البحثيه انا بحكمها ااا للنشر في المجلات
العلميه المعتبره في يعني اي احد يعني كثر
الابحاث العلميه الموجوده اليوم ما تنشر
وتنشر في مجلات لا تعتبر هذه مفترض انه
مثلا كمان ما ينظر لها ولذا يصبح فيه مشهد
همم علم همم
تقل فيه الانحيازات وهذا افضل شيء موجود
او كلام صحيح ابو عمر وهذا هو اللي طار
العام يعني خلينا نقول ال- ال- البحث
العلمي والعلم المفروض يصير بهذا الاسم
ثاني
وخلينا نقول نسبه صراحه كبيره من الابحاث
نسبه كبيره
الان
من ضمن الاشياء السلبيه من ضمن الصندوق
الاسود في جانبي المظلم
انه في عمليه احيانا رسمه لها سمى رسمه
الاكاديميه
انه تيجي شركه شركه دواء
وتجي العبد الله البريدي
وتكون نبي بحث يثبت انه هذا الدواء
الفلاني والغذاء الفلاني يعطي النتيجه
ابعث المجله
طيب الان تقول ان عندهم تحكيم يسمى تحكيم
قائم على القالب الاعمى بمعنى انه اسم
المؤلف غير كذا خير شو اللي يصير حتى امري
لمن المجال نفسه متورطه بالرشوه داخله
ما العلاقه بس انه ايش هو ارسل المحكمين
البحث من ناحيه الشكليه ابو عمر
لكن مضمون
ولذلك تخيل
الناس
مثلا
العلاج الفلاني ما له الاثار الجانبيه
الفنيه
فانا اروح العينات عينات مضروبه عينه من
المرضى اقول مثلا اخذت 300 مثلا
مبحوث تمام وانه صار عندهم كده بس نضبط
النتائج الاحصائيه النتائج الاحصائيه تكون
مضبوطه بطريقه يكون فيه خطا تمام
اخلي الاثار الجانبيه قليله
الغذاء الفلاني
بهذه الطريقه يعني
مين يكاد ما يكون موجود يعني ضئيل جدا هذا
التجارب والله
ابو عمر
بس ما تعتمد على مجرد ابحاث ونشات في
المجلات
التعلم الشركات ترعب والقران الشريف في
شركات اكبر من الميزانيه الدول
همم بعمر انت بدل مثلا شركه مثلا والله
عندك 100 مليون ترى عادي تحط 30 مليون
تسويق ولا لا ايه هذول يحطوهم يحطوهم
مليارات ما عندهم مشكله ويشرون ولذلك
شيء الحين يعني مثلا لما نسمع مثلا والله
غذاء معين سعد يا اخي بروز غير عادي على
مستوى العالم غذا معين ومكونات معينه
ادويه معينه يراد لان تصعد او يراد لان
كده
فالمقلق ابو عمر انه هذه الابحاث انها في
تزايد لماذا لان وصلنا لصلعنه المعرفه هذه
ترى اخطر شيء المعرفه في التاريخ اول ترى
غير اسامه
عشان كده احنا بصراحه بتراثنا العربي
الاسلامي
المعرفه افترضنا ما تصير مصدر قوتي
عشان ما تكتبي كلام ترى هذا الصدق يعني ما
اعرفه العلم افترض ما يكون ماستر اساسي
طبعا انا استاذ جامعي الان مثلا تمام واخذ
اخذ اخذ
التمام بس اني انا استاذ جامعي
امارس التدريس التعليم ما له علاقه بالبحث
العلمي
البحث العلمي امارس وجزء من كذا لكن يفترض
انه ما يكون سبب مثلا محاوله زياده في
الدخل
بالضبط انت تدري الان انه البحث العلمي
وانا ضده صار في شيء اسمه مكافات باحثين
على الناس اللي ينشرون ابحاث مثلا منشور
بقواعد بيانات ايسكو بس
ترى هذا باب للابحاث المفبركه والمضروبه
ايش هي الحين اشوف الجامعات الحين يقول لك
الجامعه الفلانيه سعوديه ولا ولا عربيه
طبعا كلامنا يمكن يكون على مستوى العالم
العربي لانه في تشابه
الجامع الفلاني يقول والله عندي انا افتخر
وحطينا
عندي 2000 بحث
ايس اي هذه ابو عمر هذه قاعده بيانات تتبع
شركه سامسونج رويترز الكنديه طبعا شركه
عالميه الان صارت كلوبر ضخمه فيها قرابه
171 مليون وثيقه بحثيه
قرابه 34000 مجله محكمه قرابه ملياراي
مرجع
بها ابحاث من عام 1930
طيب وعمر
يعني الغرب حول المعرفه الى قيمه اقتصاديه
دخل عليهم مئات من العراق للاسف احنا
قاعدين نشتغل لهم بالعالم
الاخر دول الاطراف بالمجان شلون
تجي المجله الحين انت الان عندك مجال ابو
عمر
عشان تدخل الاي اس اي يعطونك شروط
لازم يصير عندك باللغه الانجليزيه هذه
الحياه
انتظام الصدور مو على كيفك يعني يعني كل
شهرين خلاص
طيب جابوا فكره
عشان في فلوس جابوا فكره اسمها معامل
الاستشهاد
عبد الرحمن ابو مالح نشر بحثا في مجله الف
واستشهد بحثك 100 مره انت بحثك افضل من
بحث عبد الله اللي ما استشهد فيه 80 او 90
مره او 40
لانه استشهد قالوا والله كذا 100 100 بحث
معامل استشهاد هذا يجوني يحسبونه على
مستوى كل المجله يعني ياخذون الاستشهادات
بكل بحث ثم يصير في معامل يسمونه امباكت
فاكتور معامل تاثير الكلمه مجله
ومعاذ يجون يصنفون المجلات بكل حقل والله
مثلا بالفيزا النظريه كذا بالفيزياء
التطبيقيه كذا
ويصنفونا والله ومعتصنفونا الف وباء وجيم
طيب
الان المجلات هذه يعني حنا بجامعات
العربيه ونفتخر
يعطي مكافحه احيانا 10000 مثل بالسعوديه
20,000 الى الاخير
الدوليه مجله عندها اجنده
اجنده بحثيه تنمويه اتخيل مجله انا
بالسعوديه ولا مصر ولا الجزائر ولا
السودان
تجي تخيل انت مثلا والله عبد الله البريدي
علشان ينشر تجد انه يعرف ايش الاولويات
وايش الاجنده قاعد انا قاعد اختمهم
بالمجان لا مو بالمجان عشان تنشر مجله
لازم تدفع 3500,000 دولار الحين 1500
دولار
قاعدين نشتغل حنه لهم بالمجان وتخيل اننا
ننشر المجلات الاصطناعي ممكن تستخدم
بلاسلحه
فيزياء بتخسات معينه كيمياء بتخصصات معينه
اما تستخدم بقى بدون معادله الاسلحه اما
تستخدم بمنتجات معينه وما عاد يبيعون
علينا مئاتها طيب انا اولى عشان كذا انا
ادعوا صراحه الى تعميق البحث باللغه
العربيه
احنا ترانا الان حنا بجليلين يعني ما ما
عدنا ترى احنا نمتلك الان جزءا كبيرا
مسرار العين
الحين تراهم يعني انه خلاص
انه
اسرار العلم
عندنا علماء ترى على اكبر التراس
والان ما يكاد يوجد تخصص علمي دقيق الا في
عشرات من العلماء العرب المسلمين بكده انا
ادعو صلاح الى اننا نعمق ابحاثنا باللغه
العربيه تراكم ويصير مثل مثل الخليصير
يعني بطاطا بحوضه
يعني يصير الابحاث تحقق لنا منتجات قيمه
اقتصاديه لنا الغرب يعني الان جالس والله
يعني انا ولذلك انا فعلا جامعات العربيه
والسعوديه الى ايقاف مكافاه التميز هذه
بلاصه وبس للاسباب اللي قلت له وتدرس
بالعكس يا اخي مكافحه العلم والباحثين
والجبون البحار بس يفترض انه تكون
محايده مستقله لا عندها يعني مكاسب او
غنائم يعني تكون عندها عمق طبعا في عولمه
مباحثين ترى عندهم خبره واعمق مني بكثير
حوض الموضوع بس يمكن ما احد تحدث عن هذا
الموضوع انه الموضوع يفترض يدرس يكون
عندنا استراتي
وعلى الصور الوطني
اما اني انا افتخر والله الجامع الفلانيه
ايسكو بس انا اعتبر انه صراحه نوع من
انواع همم يعني الجانب الشكلاني وهمم نوع
نوع الخداع يمكن يعني
يعني حتى الجامعات ترى ما فكروا فيه من
قبل الطريقه هذه بس بصراحه انا افترض ما
اخدع نفسي انا اخته نفسي بطريقه رائعه
لانه بفهمك همم
ناظم النقاط هذه بس في تحدي يعني همم واحد
انه ايش الحوافذ اللي انا باعطيها
الدكاتره في السعوديه
النظام اللي انا بخلي في حوافز معي هنا
اليوم يمكن المكافات او حتى التركيات
الترقيات ما تتم الاعلام
كيف اخلي الموضوع ما تحث الناس انها تبحث
لازم
اثنين اذا باخذها انشرها عندهم
انه ما في مجلات عربيه ولا سعوديه يعني
فهمم
العلميه عندي محترقه وانها غير مكتمله
فتخلي تحدي يصير صعب انك تنتج لحالك فهمت
لازم تضبط البنيه يعني المنظومه كامله
ثلاثه
اعتقد ان العالم اليوم خلاص يعني يستسلم
الموضوع هذا وان الكل ينشر بالانجليزي
فحتى الصينيين هم اللي عندهم اكثر همم
نضجا في المنظومه العلميه ينشرون برده
الابحاث العلميه لا تكون يعني اعتبره الا
اذا نشرت في الانجليزيه
فحتى الصين والهند همم بالمليارات ينشره
بالانجليزي همم
بالنسبه للاهداف المستهدفات اتوقع انها
تختلف من الدوله الدوله وانهم ياخذون
بالاعتبار مثلا زي صندوق الدولي صناديق
الدوليه للشركات الكبرى انها تعتبر
احترامات الدول المختلفه وفي عندنا اعتقد
ان الرؤيه اعلنت عن ااا
ايش الاطروحات البحثيه اللي تبغاها محدده
انها الاستدامه يعني خمسه اشياء اللي
مفترض ان للبحث ركز عليها عشان تعطي
الدعملها
طيب ابو عمر شوف انت قلت صراحه همم كلام
مهم ممتاز وجميل انه الموضوع فعلا يفترض
انه يدرس بطريقه استراتيجيه افترض انك
تحفز الباحثين معنويا صحيح نائب انا اتفق
مع المبدا هذا وانا ترى يمكن بعض الزمن
طبعا يعتبون علي وكذا انهم مثلا دعوت مثلا
ايقاف مكافاه تتميز قطع الرزق قضيه بالعكس
والله انا اسعد الناس يعني انا ترى مره
انا كنت عضو مجلس العلمي الجامعه وكان في
بحث يفترض يروح عشان ياخذ مكافاه انا وقفت
انا حطيت ملاحظه على نفسي والله
اي شيء يدخل يعني القضيه ترى لانه الحمد
لله تاخذ راتب وانت بخير يعني
يعني يجيك 10000 وهو بعدين ولا 15000
وبعدين اتطمن مبلغ زين ما نقول ما نقول في
شيء بس انه بس في الشاهد انه انا ما عمل
مكافاه خاصه انه بصراحه الاساتذه يعني
دخلوهم عاديه وترى على فكره كل العالم
العالم يعني دخلك ترى ما انت بتصير تاجر
انت وسياره بنتلي عاديه من وسط الناس
ولبسك انا وروحك وسفراتك ترى
روح المجال
لكن انا ما كل ذلك بس بالعكس
المادي بالعربي
علم نظري نسميه ابحث نظريه وبحث تطبيقيه
انا ابحث النظريه تسمى بيت هذا متعلق فعلا
هذا يتعلق بنيه العلم عشان كذا لما انت
تعطي بحث نظري بيتك انت فعلا على مستوى
انك فعلا تقدم بحثا يسهم في تطوير العلم
ذاته
وهذا شيء عظيم
وهذا للانسانيه انك تطور العلم الجانب
الثاني ترى اكثر الابحاث والابحاث
التطبيقيه برايد
لاني انا ممكن اروح كده بالتطبيق ممكن
اروح كذا مكان كذا
اه نيجي هنا بحذ التطبيقي ابو عمر طيب انا
بالبحث الاول انا مع تقدم العلم للانسانيه
لكن لما اجي الابحاث التطبيقيه وترى اكثر
نسبه كبيره جدا حتى التطبيقيه هل اروح
للمسارات اللي تخدم غيري ولا مسيرات اللي
تخدمني انا
المسار العلم اللي للعلم للعلم انا قلت
تراه هذه لله ما اعرف انسانيه افترض فيها
ما عندي مشكله ترى على فكره انا ما اعرف
الفكره العربي
حنا محنا صراحه نؤمن بان المعرفه مشاعه
عشان كده مع لكن اجيت الابحاث تطبيقيه انا
ما اروح ابحث للاشياء اللي تخدم غيري
وربما بطريقه تؤذيني او تضرني بشكل مباشر
او غير مباشر
وانما الاشياء اللي فعلا تختمني عشان كده
الموضوع
يبي دراسه عندنا مجلات ترى على فكره عندنا
مجلات سعوديه ترى على ارقام المجلات عربيه
على الارقام وبعدين وش اللي يخلي ما يكون
عندي مجالات اكثر راقيه ادعم ادعم يعني
ولذلك انا اعتبر ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
رؤيه الطموحه
وثقله الاقتصادي السياسي الديني وموقعها
وكل المقدرات العظيمه ترى احنا قادرين
نكون حنا نمثل النموذج العالم العربي كله
نعطيه مثلا استراتيجيه
نموذج عمل
وبعدين تربط الابحاثي ابو عمر تربط بشيء
واحد اسمه التاثير البحوث يعني انا عشان
اعطيك مكافاه ابي اكتضمن انه في اثر
بطريقه مباشره
على اي شيء تنموي او تعلق بجوده الحياه
عندي في دليل ترجمه الدكتور صالح النصارى
جامعه الملك سعود عنوان الكتاب دليل تاثير
البحوث العلميه
وطرح طرح ممتاز يعني بحثك اما ابو عمر
اما يغير الافكار والمواقف الطريق ايجابيه
يحسن الوعي بطريقه معينه
جديده جديده
نحاس الواجب نحاس لما يجعلني اقوى اجعلني
افضل لانه ترى المعرفه والعلم بالغرب ترى
يقولون المعرفه قوه
معرفه قوه عشان كده ترى ينادي بعضهم الى
ابقاء بعض الاشياء في العلم من ضمن
الاسرار ولا تعطونا العلم الثالث
شو يعني شفناها اليوم في حرب الامريكيه
الصينيه انه منعت اي شيء له علاقه
يعني الصين
اعتبرت ان خوارزميه تيك توك
الى امريكا
صارت امريكا
لدرجه انهم حطوا قانون مؤخرا قالوا في
شركه صينيه تشتغل في هذا القطاعه يختار
جنسيته ويشتغل
بجنسيه الامريكيه امريكي
كل اتجاه انا ترى حنا بفكر عربي اسلامي
عندنا حنا لان عندنا نظرتين احنا
شيء يعني مبدا يسمى مساله العلم هل العلم
سائل ولا ما يساعد
يعني هل في مسائل دينيه واخلاقيه للعلم
ولا ممكن العلم نخليه بعض الناس يقول لك
لا خلي العلم لا تجيب طاري الدين والاخلاق
بالعلم خلوا العلم يمشي
طيب انا اقول وحده الذي لا يساعدني والله
كل من لا يساعد رجل
يدخل لي مجالات ضاره الانسانيه
وتخليق انسان وقطع غيار بطريقه معينه
والان حتى مع الشدود مثلا قضيه انه خلاص
والمواصلات اللي تبون
يعني يعني هذه المسارات لا احنا نقول انه
العلم مشعل يشاهد بالمنظر الدين الاخلاقي
علشان لانه مره ثانيه ما له علاقه بالانتر
هذا التطبيقات العلم حين التطبيقات
وانا اوجه العلم للجانب اللي فعلا فيه خير
في جوانب ايجابيه الانسانيه اما اني اقول
لا وكذا وانه كان العلم خرج عفريت خرج من
القمقم ولا اقدر اسيطر عليه معناته كارثه
اتوقع الحين
تقدر
تاخذ انها تقدر تمنع الامراض
تقدر اصطناعي يمكن انه يخلي البشر يعني
يعيشون الحياه افضل وتطور
ممكن تاخذها بتخلي في تحكم عالي من
الشركات والحكومات
صح صح
موب انه ناخذ نظره بعمر ضديه تماما بابحث
الجنيه اغلقها كما بديناها يعني لو حاكم
الجينات على انه يعني المقال حق انه اليوم
تقدر تصمم طفلك
والانابي واستئجار الرحم ومدري ايش انها
ممكن تاخذها مثلا لما يعني في المثال هذا
بس تقدر تاخذ برضه في المكان الصحيح
الاطفال اللي عندهم
اصاباتهم
اولاده يعني
ندردشه خفيفه طبعا ابدا بس انه انا بس
اقرر مبدا مساعده العلم
انا انا كعربي مسلم هل انا مع مساعده الام
ولا للعلم اخلي مفتوح يعني هنا الفرق
عادي يجي فريق من العلماء والخبره العلماء
متخصصين في الجينات وعلامات دين وعلماء
انسان يجلسون ربما سنه يا ابو عمر يمكن
يطلعون ويحتاجين ليست قديم معقده فعلا
اشكاليه نحن لا نفت بشيء بس احنا نقدر ان
والله العلم سعد في مساعده دينيه اخلاقيه
عاد وش عمليه الضبط
وعمليه التوجيه هنا ياتي ياتي دور البحث
العلمي الرصيد اللي يضبط المساله ولا مثل
يعني مجالات بس بدي ارجع بعمر القضيه انت
قلت يا ابو عمر
انا اشوف انه مهم وهي قضيه انك قلت انه
العالم سلم بالانجليزي
[موسيقى]
نفس فكره طبعا هو يعني يخلص الى النوم
الانجليزي
شخص يتحدثون اكثر من 2020 دوله انه
المجلات وبعدين فعلا يعني في خضوع
واستسلام عجيب حتى داخل الدول الاوروبيه
تعرفين نقول والله فرنسيين معتزين بلغهم
الدراسات العليا
مره ثانيه السوق يعني
يعني اقتصاد سلامه
لكن صدقني هذا سيضر الالمان الفرنسيين كل
هذه الشعوب التي لماذا ابو عمر
التفكير يتعلق باللغه انت لا تستطيع ان
تفكر بعمق الا بلغتك الام
عن تدري عدد الكلمات باللغه العربيه 12
مليون اعظم لغه واكثر اللغات ذخائر
اللفظيه وقدره اشتقاقيه هذا موضوع اخر
لسنا حديث عن سمات اللغه العربيه
خلك اي لغه لو تحكي عن اللغه الارديه لو
لغه الام لغه ورديه انت عشان تصل المرحله
التفكير التجريدي الخلاق الابداعي لازم
تفكر بلغه اذا فكرت بلغه اجنبيه بيصير
تفكيرك مثل تفكير الطفل اللي يفكر
بالحسيات طفوله الاولى
تجريديه ما عنده قضيه سعاد قضيه اراد قضيه
حريه قضيه كل هذه المعاني اجتماع ما عنده
لما يكبر
ترى احنا بعدينا المرحله الطفل ترى
بالانجليزي
وكل واحد يكون انا يعني اتفت باللغه
يعني مهما كنت ترى
نقول الباحث اللي يفكر ويكتب باللغه
الانجليزيه
هو مساعد بحث
لانك ما تصل ما تصل مستوى التجريديه وتفكر
بالبرادايم والنظريات والعمق اللي يفكر
فيها اهل اللغه الانجليزيه والامريكي
والكندي هذه لغتهم
3,000 4,000 10,000 15,000 كلمه انجليزي
يا محدود لكن باللغه العربيه
ايميل كلمه مصمته مثل مثل الحجر المصمت
ايميل
لكن لما اقول لك بريد شبكه
شبكه
معناته في طرفين
اشتباك
لعمليه الشبكه تحديات للاشتباك
الكلمه هذه جالسه تولد عندك ممكن تطلع
فكره ابداعيه ملهمه جدا شلها قيمه
اقتصاديه ليش لانه شبكي وبريد
يخليك تفكر غير ايمي ايميل كلمه مصمته
تعلمت بس انه هش يا الفلاني اللي سما اللي
هو البريد الالكتروني
وترى هذا مثال بسيط لكنه لو كان معنا وقت
ممكن نعطي امثله كثير انه مبين اهميه انك
تفكر اذا ابو عمر القضيه مين ترى قضيه انك
سلمى وكلاء انت الان تنزل مرتبه الباحث
الى مرتبه مساعد الباحث ومن التفكير
الخلاق الى تفكير عادي
انت لما تدرس الماده مثلا فيزياء
والكيمياء للطب لما تدرس اللغه تسمع الشرح
بالعربي مثل لما تشرح بالانجليزي مهما
كانت الانجليزيه
باللغه العربيه باللغه الام ومع البحث
والنشر باللغه العربيه من اجل العمق
والابداع يا اخي ملينا من المجرد انا انا
ماني مجرد كثير
جدا عشان بس مجرد ترقيه ترى ما لها علاقه
مره ثانيه يعني
محدوده اللغه وذلك كان نقول اللغه ترى
مثابه الثقب جدار الوجود
يعني يعني الوجود الان جدار عشان تثقل
وتشوف ماذا تحتاج لغه بتخيل انك انت الثقب
باللغه الاجنبيه ترى الثقب صغير لكن لما
تيجي الثقب بلغتك والا متجدد الثقب كبير
من الجدار عشان كده
تكتشف اشياء وكذا اكثر الموضوع جدا عميق
ولذلك انا ارجو ان اقتنع بصراحه ان افكر
بهذه اللغه لغه الام عشان نبدا وننشر
ونحقق تراكميه لمستقبلنا بعد 50 سنه افكر
انا 2300 مره
اتفق معك الى حد
مختلف معك يعني ان الله اذا بناخذ
الابحاث وانه
جودتها رديئه في السعوديه وعربيه
اللغه
خذ الابحاث الدينيه اللي مفترض انها ما
تبدا ولا تنتهي الا بالعربيه وتلقاه عربيه
يعني متى كانت في بحث همم عليه الكلام في
العشرين 30 سنه الماضيه يعني ما في شيء
يتكلم فهي من رداءه المنظومه البحثيه همم
طيب ارد عليك ابو عمر
الله يخليك
اولا يعني يكون مثلا في ابحاث في حق معين
ضعيفه او رديئه
بيبي بالقضيه عامل واحد فعلا يعني انت
وضعت يك صراحه على شيء ممتاز وانه في عده
حوامل صحيح
لكن ترى على فكره ترى الابحاث
السعوديه والعربيه في عدد من الحقول
الدينيه واللغويه ترابحث على مستوصف
الاسره صراحه
ما نعطي كلام كذا على عوايني كمان وقال
ترى في الاقتصاد الاسلامي مثلا في مصر في
الاسلاميه
في ابحاث الفقه وصول الفقه على على يعني
حصانه درجه من الرصانه ممتازه في ابحاث
ضعيفه وبحاثيه بس علشان يعني نعطي للناس
صراحه
اللغه العربيه بحث محلقه ورائعه وجميله
ورصينه وملهمه وتستحق انه الترجمه ابحث
انا قصدي ايضا انه يعني احنا بس ودنا نعطي
دول حقهم وانه فيها ممتاز وكذا لكنه هلله
بحث
يعني اكثرها همم وصل لموسى المطلوب لا
يعني في مشاكل بالمنهج في ضعف في المنهج
سطحيه بالمنهج التقليد والاعراف البحثيه
لك عليها صح يعني
الجانب الاخر متعلق يعني قضيه اللغه مثل
ما قدرت ابو عمر يعني يبقى انه انك انت
تشتغل وتفكر بلغتك صدقني انك ستكون يعني
مثلا حتى انا ضربت امس كنت في بحث
في مجمع الملك سلمان للعالم اللغه العربيه
وقلت لهم مثلا هو البحث الصراحه بعنوان
يعني يرد عليه عنوان صادم ايش يقول
العنوان ماذا يخسر العالم اذا رطنا
بالانجليزيه اوكي العالم كله تراه لما
اتكلم عن المسلمين او السعوديه وعلما
العالم عشان كده نتقمصت شخصيه العالم
وحركت لسان العالم عشان
يفصح عن الخسائر اذا رطنا هذا العالم كله
بالانجليزيه فقط لا خسائر كبير يعني مثلا
تيجي مثلا الحب
بين الرجل والمراه بالانجليزي
في اللغه العربيه في اكثر من 10 كلمات
تعبير عن طبعا لما اتكلم اذا شوف الانسان
العربي
وكما قالت العربيه يعني جل ان يراو كذا
وكذا وكذا يعني يعني الظاهر هذه الانسان
العربي وضح لها تضاريس
مقياس طيفي
ودراجات تخيل مثلا انت لو انت بتفكر ورحت
للحب بالادبيات ما تلقى الالف ما تيجي
فكره
الدراجات الحب وتضاريس وانك تشوف كل مرحله
مش ممكن يسوي الحال المحبوب ويسوي العاشق
والمعشوق وكلامك انت ممكن تصل نتائج يعني
مثلا
العلاقات
الغربيه تجد مثلا
الحسد عندنا بالاسلام عندنا غلطه طيب وين
الغبطه ترى ما في كلمه انجليزيه تعبر عن
الخبطه ابدا
اذا انت
اذا العالم خسر هذا المعنى ولا لا خسر لان
الغبطه يعني انك تتمنى مثل ما عند اخر
دونه تمني زوال هذا الشيء عن الاخر معنى
انسان يراك
يعني مشاعر ايجابيه ملهمه غير الحسد مشاعر
سالبه حارقه انك تتمنى ما عند الغير مع
زواله
اذا الانسان الكلي مجرد عن الدين والثقافه
استفاد منكم لما استفاد اذن فكرت بلغتك
استفاد معنى عظيم ترى
عشان كذا لما اقول بالانجليزي
كلمه اجنبيه
والعالم تراها يعني يكسب اذا خرج عن ثقب
الانجليزيه الارضيه جدا ترا هذا نظره
فلسفيه نعتقد ان انا قادرين انه الهم
العالم والانسان اشياء كثيره
بتخسر البشريه اذا تكلمت كل كل يعني اذا
تكلم العالم باللغه العربيه باللغه
العربيه صحيح
انا ضد الاحاديه
كلو انا
ابو عمر
عشان كذا وانا قلت امس كان كان
مسؤول كبير بالامم المتحده ممثل
العام المتحده
مهندس صلاح مصري عربي كان ممثل حاضر
اللغه العربيه
يعني
زميله في اليونسكو شغاله والله نسيت
جنسيتها
فترحت عليه فكره
تخيل خساره العالم ابو عمر اذا صار في حدث
نسميه حنا موت لغه
متى تموت اللغه ترى الفرق بين موت اللغه
واندثار اللغه
لما تكون اللغه موجوده
وفي ناس يتحدثونها لكن ما يتحدثون بالحياه
العامه يتحدثون مثلا بالمجالات الدينيه
مثلا مثل ما صار مع مثلا مع العبريه وصلت
الاندفاع والحياه العامه يتحدثون بالروسيه
يتحدثون البولنديه
الغرب
وفقط العبريه يستخدم
الموت
لما يموت اخر واحد في العالم يتحدث هذه
اللغه
يا الله
العالم خسر كم كبير من الاداب والمعارف
والمعلومات يمكن انا عندي مرض موجود عندهم
العلاج
عندي معنى معين موجود في هذه اللغه
خلاص
والتقاليد والممارسات والتجارب والاعشاب
وغير الاعشاب والصحه وكذا
مره خلاص انتهت فانا قلت لهم
وامسك مثل الاستاذ اللي بيمثل الامم
المتحده امير المتحده قلتله ليتكم تعملوه
فيلم
سينمائي يصور
بشاعه تموت
صراحه اني ارسم
موضوع ليس سهلا بس ممكن بعض المبدعين يصور
الحقيقه هو ممكن يكون فيلم قصير يعني يكون
كبير بس انه هي المقصد اذا انا على
التفكير باللغه الام لانه يحافظ على كل
المعارف الانسانيه ويجعل الانسان همم
خلاقه مبتكره همم اخر حاجه همم
النقاشه للغات همم في همم يعني بعطيهم
حقهم جامعه الملك عبد الله العلوم التقنيه
انجليزيه
همم رائع جدا
العالم كله همم وينافس على مستوى العالم
يفوزون جوائز عالميه همم وتنتج من خلالها
منتجات رايه جدا فاحس مثل ما ضبطت
المنظومه البحثيه وفرغوا الباحثين من
التدريس الى انهم يركز تمام والمهم
الاداريه بنقدر ننتج وطريقه تفكيري قد
تكون بالعربيه حسوني انا بترجمها الى
الانجليزيه بالكتابه البحث
والتالي هي ليست القضيه انه خلاص انه ما
نكتب بالانجليزي
بس اني اسلم واخضع على الاقل على جانب
الفلسفه النقدي
الظاهره لاني انا انظر 234
نتائج البحث الجيد الرصيد وبابا انجليزي
ما فيش اشكال
الى ما في اشكال انا اتوقع ان اللغه
الانجليزيه يعني مفترض ان ما في اداه
اتجاه بس ولا في تسليم لها بالضبط ففي
مكان في النصف بالضبط
في الدكتور اللي ذكرت الدكتور الفيزياء
اللي كتب كتاب نمو العلم ولا نمو المعرفه
همم تمسكن الدنيا
فهو الدكتور في الفيزياء تماسكنه
فيلسوف فيلسوف علما وتاريخ او او متخصب
تاريخ العلم فهل الفلسفه
شيء يؤخذ كذا على الجنب بقول له شيء تحصل
عليه وتكون دكتور فلسفه
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
ايش رايك على اساس كاس العالم
اعطي مثال عشان نبين انواع المعرفه من كاس
العالم طيب
الفلسفه
الهمه تسجل هدف بطريقه جديده وبحيله لو
بدربكه لو جالها دربكه
العلم بيسجل هدف بطريقه مدروسه ما هي
بطريقه جديده
طيب معرفه دينيه
تيجي تقول لك سجل هدف بس يا اخي شوف البعد
الغالي شوف البعد الاخلاقي لا تكسر لا
تودي احد
معقول انك تصيب احد بطريقه يعني حلو
المعرفه الادبيه والفنيه يقول لك سجل هدف
بطريقه جميله دبل كيك
حتى الاشياء بسيطه استطيع ان اوضتها علشان
افهم المعارف طيب ناخذ المعرفه الفلسفيه
المعرفه الفلسفيه طبعا في تعريف كثير جدا
وش الفلسفه وفي خلافه
لكن المعرفه الفلسفيه بشكل عام هي تدور
حول فكره الاسس اسس الاشياء اصول الاشياء
علل الاشياء اسباب الاشياء
وتحاول ان تدرس الانسان
والعالم والطبيعه والمتفزيقه الشيء غير
الماده وغير الماده
وتحاول تركز على المضمون عشان كذا احنا
نقول الفلسفه يعني تعتمد على شيء انا سميه
برهانيه مضمونيه يعني قوه مضمون تحاول
تعطيك مضمون قوي تقنعك عن طريق المضمون
وبترد يعني تطرح مفاهيم جديده عشان كذا
قلت انا بطريقه جديده وحيده اذا عندك
مفاهيم تهز المفاهيم المفاهيم الساقطه
تتهزه في تنتج تنتج مفاهيم جديده تنتج
مناهج جديده في التفكير بالتالي احيانا
بعض الحقول ابو عمر العلم
ما تطور الا اذا جاءت الفلسفه وشقت له
حقول جديده قبل احيان يطرح فيلسوف
المجال معين
يطرح احيانا ابو عمر
قضيه فلسفيه
ويش شكلك طريقه تفكيره
هذا منظر
فلسفه الان فرنسي
تهجر طرق التفكير السابقه
وتفكر بطريقه او بارا دائم جديد في العلم
خلينا نلاحظ هذا الحين تنظير عامول
العلماء والمخترعين يحاولون يصلون الحين
الاضاءه جايه الاحتراق
اكيد طاقه وتشعل في النار
باي شيء من غير احترام
شفت العظمه كيف
الفلسفه احيانا تعطيك طرق تفكير احيانا
طبعا احيانا تجيء بطريقه
اه يحصل هذا بس انه تبقى انك انك هيات
المكان وبتري نعم يجي العلم ويضع مناجاه
التفكير لا
الفلسفه تزعل اذا سميتها فعل طبعا الفلسفه
هي هي الفلسفه تنظر نفسها مثل الطبيب
والعلم مثل فني المعمل
العلاج واذا احتجت اختبار ترسل المعامله
الفنيه والعلم
بصراحه انا احب اطرح هذا المثال لانه
يبين فعلا قيمه قيمه الفلسفه في الفلسفه
الفلسفه العلم هي طريقه التفكير تصنع
مناهج تصنع مفاهيم ايييه تخليك تطلع كمان
من صندوق الى صندوق اخر مثل انك قطيع
هذا الدور عظيمه عشان كذا مع انه ترى داخل
المره الثانيه بغينا نرجع الفكره الغربي
ترى فكره غرب الحديث ترى مو عادي كيف
باختصار ابو عمر
العلم الحديث لما تطور
بالحداثه وما بعد الحادثه تتكلم عن القناه
التاسعه عشر والعشرين بصراحه وصل الدرجات
لما العلم تطور
الفلسفه
وكرنا يقول لم يعد الهاربه الا تموت يقصد
فلسفه
يعني قريب قريب من اعدام
كلام فاضي
كلام فاضي في النهايه اكرام كثير بس مو
غير مفيد ففيه تيار عادي
تحلل تفسر كلام العلماء اللي يحتاج تفسير
بس
يعني قلبه ولا انا قلت الطبيب الفلسفه وما
عمل الفانيلا صار الفيلسوف وهو بيعمل
الفني يعني العالم جاب نتائج وكلام غير
واضح تجي انت تتكسر
مثل المواعيد عند الدكتور بس مجرد يحل
التمارين لكن ليشرح النظريه وكده الدكتور
في تيار عادي
سم فلسفه انت بتغلط طبعا في امريكا في
اوروبا
الفلسفه انتشر وبعدين يقولون الفلسفه ما
في مره ثانيه المعرفه ما في قيمه اقتصاديه
جلسين يعطيكم رواتب ما في كلام كثير من
غيرها العلم هو اللي يجيها ولا ايه
فهذا التيار يعني الحقيقه انه مقبل
بخلافنا نحن بدانا ندرك يعني بطريقه
متناهيه قيمه الفلسفه بطريقه جيده بس انه
الخطوره مره ثانيه ابو عمر انه في ناس
يمكن داخل علم من العربي الاسلامي يتحمس
الفلسفه اكثر من الناس
الفلسفه يعني انه يخلي الفلسفه هي المصدر
الاوحد للمعرفه غلط
يخليها لحد الاسماء يخلي لها ايمن انا غير
صحيح لانه المعرفه دينيه هي الاسمى
والاعلى في مجاري المعرفه العلميه في مجال
معرفه
يقلقني يعني اقصاء الفلسفه يعني تخسر هذا
العام
والمفاهيم والمناهج وايضا ان الرفع من شان
الفلسفه بطريقه يعني متشنجه وبطريقه كده
في نصف ايضا مره ثانيه
همم في انه الفلسفه همم يعني
يعني فكره افقيه بينما كل العلوم الثانيه
تكون عموديه يا سلام عليك
الفلسفه لها بعد اخر بعيدا كل العلوم
الثانيه فالفلسفه تدخل في الدين
فسادخل في العلوم التطبيقيه في العلوم
التجريبيه في الفيزياء في كل ست الحاله
هي اسماء
الثانيه والله شوف ابو عمر
الى نقطه الجده ممتاز واحنا نفرق ما بين
تراكميه الموجوده بالفلسفه والعلم
الله الفلسفه طوابق عمارات جنب بعض
العلم ادوار فوق بعض
عشان كده احنا نقول فلسفه
تراكميه افقيه غير تجاوزيه
بينما العلم تراكمي راسيه تعاقبيه
العلم لما تيجي نظريه
100% بس في الغالب العام لما تيجي نظريه
تنسف النظريه السابقه يعني يعني يعني
انا اشتغل
يعني غطى على نيوتن مع انه في اجزاء نيوتن
صحيح طبعا بس انه بالتالي العلم فعلا ينسخ
لكن تيجي الى الفلسفه لا انت تعمل منظور
مدخل
فلسفه مدرستيه حط حط هنا يجي واحد يحطه
بجنبه ولذلك في استدعاء ترى الافكار مو
غلب القدم فلسفه
مع اننا بالعلم كنا نتوقع توهمنا انه خلاص
نسب كل شيء لا في استدعاء عشان كده بس
اشكال لو كلمه جميله يقول القدماء اكثر
شباب منها
فيفي في استدعاء فعلا في الفلسفه هذا جانب
يعني يعطيها فعلا قيمتها
طبعا انا اقول انه المعرفه الدينيه هي
الاسماء بالنسبه لنا كمسلمين المعرفه
الفلسفيه لها قيمه كبيره ثم تاتي
تحتهما العلم والادب
مش حاجه العلم الفلسفه
العلم يحتاج الفلسفه
لاكتشاف همم مجالات جديده لان مشكله العلم
ابو عمر انه يبي موضوع محدد ومضمون وموسوق
ويعرفه وكذا وكذا
الاول اتكلم يعني الحريه لا مش بيعطيك
يعطيك سؤال يعطيك كذا في فتح همم مجالات
جديده للتفكير فتح حقول معرفيه جديده عبر
سؤال عبر فكره
واحد بعد خمسه 50 100 سنه
جديده
اجانب الاخر من انه في كلمه جميله
الام ترى مثل الانسان اللي يعني كذا مستر
راسه يمشي يمكن يطيح بحفره يمكن يطيح بكذا
يعني طيب اذا ما كان يفكر نفسه مين يفكر
بالعلم
يعني تفكر
نيابه عن العلم بالعلم
تراه المساله دينيه فلسفيه
وبعدين انتم رايحين بالطريقه دي لا لا هذه
الطريقه مثل ما قلت لك مثلا فكره مثلا
العلم تراه متشبث مثلا بفكره انه اذا جاء
بارادايم معين يمشي عليه لانه صح لانه
العلم ترى عنده وثوقيه عالي تيجي فرسه
تقول لها ترى موثوقيه نسبيه
وذلك هذا المنظرين علم الاجتماع يقول افضل
اذا صار في نظريه افضل شيء يقول ثاني افضل
نظريه
واذا جاءت واحده
دائم
عنده ثقيل فلسفه بتقول لك ترى مخطي ترى
مفهوم كذا مفهوم وتضعض ضعيف
فهذه من الجوانب الملهمه من الفلسفه للعلم
وطبعا العلم افاده الفلسفه
ليش يعني يعني طبعا الجانب الاكثر انه
الفلسفي في العلم لكن حتى العلم ترى ممكن
يفيد الفلفل فلسفه بانه كان يقول العلم
يقول الفلسفه يعني
انت تتحدثين بطريقه
تنتبه لنفسه وتضبط تضبط يعني صار في حدود
ومعالم
همم فلسفه كانوا ان العلم والله يهبط وهل
المنهج هالدقه انا بعكسه مو مو بنفس
الصرامه
الفلسفه يعني خلينا نقول فهد طيب مين اللي
حدث يعني
هذا التيار الحديث الفكره غربي
مين اللي يحدد انه هذا مو بعده مثلا تقدر
تاخذها على شيء ثاني بس احبها مثل همم
طيب ابو عمر هذا ممتاز شف فعلا احنا وصلنا
في الفتره خير بالعلوم الزاعف طيب
ممتاز
للعلم الحقيقه
ضابط بسيط برضه بالقران قناه القران
ودليل
غمض وراء ايجابي ولا دائره الله
برامج اللغه العصبيه اللي صار
الحين
من اللي يعني العلم نفسه
فالعلم مو بقادر نفسه يفرق بينه وبين علم
الزائف من اللي يفكر يعطيك الفلسفه مره
ثانيه انت تحتاج الفلسفه عشان تمايس ما
بين اجزاء العلم الحقيقي
اسمه كاربور
هذا نمساوي يهودي همم راح البريطانيا
كنت بقابله انا بصراحه
انا رحت الدكتوراه بريطانيا 16 يناير عام
مانشستر
99 عندنا على طول انا يمكن من اوائل الناس
اللي عملت بريد شبكه
98 عند دوائر معينه هاتف وكذا
للناس
فانا قلت اول ما اروح ان شاء الله هناك
بريطانيا ابي اروح لندن
لاني عندي اهتمام باستمرار الفلسفه العلم
اللي صار المهم يوم رحت هناك وعتساره
الانترنت يعني متوفره وكذا وابحث والقاوم
توفى 1994 انا ما دريت ههه
[ضحك]
المهم راح الموضوع طيب
طلع كتاب عام 1932 بالالمانيه لانه نمساوي
مره ثانيه يعني فكر بلغه الام هي
الالمانيه
منطق الكشف العلمي
المهم الموضوع اللي نستله من هذا اللي
يهمنا هو موضوع التفريق ما بين العلم
الحقيقي لانه هو كان من يوم عمره 19
يقول بدها تشتغل معه
يقول اكتشفت
جاء واحد وقال
ان عندي طفل ومتى يشرح قال خلاص
يقولوا شفت انه يستخدم
كانه النظريه بتاع كله بس وذلك يقال يتفسر
كل شيء لا تفسر اي شيء
خطيره الكلام
عرفت انه يقول عمر تخيل عمره 16 يجي بباله
السؤال اللي طرحته انت عمرك 19 ما الفرق
بين النظريه العلميه والنظريه الزاحفه
قبل التحقيق للتكذيب
يعني انا لما لانه مثلا نظريه مثلا فروت
واحد من المحلين نفسيين واحد
جاء
وقتل طفلك
تيجي نظريه تقول ايه هو على اساس شعور
كذا وكذا
طيب طيب
ايه ده الزائفه
لكن تيجي نظريه مثلا الطقس
تيجي نظريه تقول لك بعد ثلاثه ايام بسوق
المطر
نصبر
كان الكلام هذا كلام فاضي
حق خبر
يعني بسال ورقه تنظيف
الحد اللي يفصل
قال ان العلم يحل اللغز
النظريه العلميه عنده لغز وتحله
يعني مثلا علم الفلك الفلك في فلك وتنجيم
الفلك في لغز انه والله وشلون حدث هذا
الحدث الفلكي وفسره انه نظرا لانه يدور
بالمسار البيضاوي بطريقه معينه وكذا وكذا
وكذا اذا في مغذي
ما
في كلك والله احنا يعني نما الى علمنا من
خلال
يعني المعرفه الحجيه الداخليه انه يصير لك
كذا طيب
وعلى اساس فبالتالي يقول العلوم الزائفه
اصلا ما عندك ما عنده ما في لغز ولا تقدر
تحله فجالها المعيار
على كل حال انا اقول همم يعني فكره تمسكون
صراحه ممكن يستفاد منها قبل التكذب فعلا
انا اشوف انها يعني صعب تطبيق
لانه العلم الحقيقي يا ابو عمر هو العلم
البرهاني يعطيك برهان
المستقبل
عشان كده انا قلت لك ابو عمر الفلسفه
برهانيه مضمونيه قوه
يعني الكلام فسر ما يقدر يعطيك شيء متماسك
يعني دليل متماسك برهان لانه ما يستخدم
التجربه وليس شلون بيعطيك وبالتالي
نوعيه براهين الفلسفه بعمر
براهينه وادله للطبع عقلاني عقلي تحليلي
استنتجي يعني في الغالب بهذه الطريقه
يعني ممكن تقبل ممكن ما تقبل عشان كده
الفلسفه ترى تحتم يعني انت ممكن فكره تجد
المؤمنين بها وتجد اشد الكافرون
الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا جزيلا لك الله
يحييك ابو عمار وانا اشكرك شكرا لك شكرا
لكم شكرا لاحمد التويجري ايمن الحمادي في
اعداد الحلقه ياسر بن غانم خلف الكاميرات
وعبد المجيد العطاس في تلوين الحلقه
وجميله عبد الاحد في التحرير والهندسه
الصوتيه ضياء الدين المدني وفي الانتاج
اصيل بافرض هذا فنجان احد منتجات شركه
ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع نشر كل الانتاج
بيحب من مدينه الرياض الاسبوع المقبل
[موسيقى]
المسلمين عندهم اعداد تجاه الفلسفه اكثر
من يعني في تلقى الفلسفه حق الضعيف عندنا
لانه حرام يخليك
لنا يحط التساؤلات هذه فلم يحطوا قدام
تساؤلات وتلقاهم يحرمونا خلونا ان هذا
طريقه
ابو عمر يعني
النظر العربيه الاسلاميه يعني النظره
التراثيه الفلسفه
النظره خلينا نقول متحفظه لكن لا يلزمك
وبعدين يشوف الجده
هي نظره متحفظه وانا ما عاد تحفظ
لكن جدا
ليش لانه التيار مره ثانيه التيار الرئيس
في الفلسفه الغربيه
هو تيار انا اسميه الفلسفه المتمرده
فلسفه المتمرده انا وضعت له تعريف
الفلسفه المتمرده هي فلسفه مستغنيه مفتقره
شو مستغنيه استغنت عن الله ابتداءا
تفتقرت انتهاء
بينما الفلسفه المؤمنه
مفتقره مستغنيه نفس الكلمتين بس تقديم
تاخير
المفتقره مستغنيه
الى الله
فلسفه الغربيه هي مشكلتها الرئيس فلسفه
متمرده تجاه الاله مثلا
الحر كلام يقول انه
ليس من المعقول المنطق عباده غير الانسان
يقصد الاله ويطالب بالتمرد يقول على اساس
كذا وكذا في طبعا الفكره العربي الاسلامي
التراثي ضد التمرد صحيح
احنا احنا مع الفلسفه المؤمنه صحيح وذلك
لما تيجي وتقر فلسفه مؤمنه مؤمنه باله وان
الاله هو الذي خلق الكون وهو وضع نواميس
ونوضع شريعه ووضع اخلاق وانت تتفلسف في
الهواء مثل لا تستطيع ان تتفلسف بها يعني
انت ما تفكر في ذات الله ولا تفكر
بالاسماء والصفات التي هو اخبرك عنها
فيجيك الاسلامي يقول لك حدد لك مجالات
التفكير لكن لا لا قدره لك لك الفكره
الغربي عشان ما عنده جوانب يفكر بجوانب
بصراحه تؤدي الى التيه وتؤدي الى الضلال
تؤدي الانحراف وتؤدي الى الشكوكيه يعني
ترى عدد من فلاسفه في الغرب قديما وحديثا
وصل له الشك يشكوك يسمى شك المطلق انه
اصلا
المعرفه نهائي
هذا امر
اختي خطيره جدا مطلقه